just look I cannot line up what looks
whatever looks
I cannot art direct one time these oil
paintings were like how do we get to
North Hollywood and I was like I don't
know and that's where I really learned
that I couldn't art direct oh my god
you've seen the title of this video it's
January favorite so let's get into the
favorite items that I oh that's the end
of that sentence let's get into the
favorite items that I have inflection is
a reflection of how well you are
communicating Henry David throw that in
the garbage that was not a good quote
not a good quote
yeah yes yes yeah actually it could snow
for the entirety of this video that some
or all these products may have been in
favorite videos before I'm sorry these
are just things that I actually enjoy
now and if I enjoyed them before well
look at that that seems to be a good
product the foundation this is
maybelline superstay better skin skin
transforming foundation it doesn't
transform my skin I put it on my skin
and I don't turn into like a lizard or a
car or helicopter a Tampa however I
think it's a really great drugstore
foundation especially if you are like me
and you like a full coverage foundation
usually go pretty heavy on my foundation
because I just like it you know like
when you wrap your body in a blanket at
night and you feel secure I just like
wrapping my face in like a foundation
blanket this is with actual see oil-free
those are just letters like that looks
like you typed out this label on your
phone and it didn't auto correct
titanium dioxide sunscreen I don't know
if I want a medium dice oxide sunscreen
on my face that sounds like an
evanescent brand of sunscreen basically
the long and short of it is the
distillation lasts a really long time
it's got great coverage it doesn't feel
super heavy and kind of pump in the top
which is just so convenient - yeah yeah
yep see ya say I hate this is from Tarte
so it's a higher end make a product but
this is their BB tinted moisturizer
either way if you like light coverage in
your foundation this is perfect for you
because it's space is just a tinted
moisturizer but sometimes I like to use
this tinted moisturizer as sort of a
moisturizer primer or yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is part
Amazonian clay full coverage foundation
totally full coverage and I really
really really love this foundation very
much is a little bit more expensive can
use this with other foundations you can
use this by itself it's like tacos you
can put whatever you want with whatever
you want yeah next yeah can't see I see
I see it oh damn and and also solidus
Too Faced melted chocolate liquefied
long-wear lipstick I'm a huge proponent
of all the Too Faced melted liquid
lipsticks those are basically they're
like lip stains that you can put on your
lip I think they're fantastic I've
talked about them in tons of other
favorite videos but this one oh I'm
wearing it right now to make this a
chocolate wine and they know what
they're doing they know what they know
what they're doing and they know what
they're doing you know what you're doing
I love you this is in the color
chocolate honey and it's this kind of
light brown lip stain that I love and it
smells so much like chocolate taking all
of my self-control and not to just grind
it directly off of my list into my mouth
right now in front of you but I care
about your opinion of me so I won't do
that I have this for a long time I never
put it on because I thought it was going
to be too brow a brown lip color I still
I don't know is that what is that then I
put it on and it's just really neutral
and it seems to go with like every
single outfit that I have I've been
trying to find like a nude lip but
because I have a paler skin tone nude
lips tend to look like I like lots my
lips and some sort of like lip accident
so this allows me to get a more neutral
color but still make my lips look like I
have lips nude snack yeah I can't see
yeah yeah I see is a scent this is
Elizabeth and James Nirvana bourbon Oh
I only drink bourbon when I don't have
any other liquors available but this is
the only kind of bourbon that I will
reach for if you don't know I have been
a huge huge huge lover of Elizabeth and
James Nirvana black in nirvana white
nicely Nirvana black and then they just
released two more sense nirvana bourbon
and Nirvana rose and Rose is a little
bit more like a sweeter smelling scent
more like a Laurel Sophie sense and
Nirvana bourbon is more of like that
musky it smells almost like you're like
the fanciest old rocking chair in the
room yeah neck yeah can't see ya see ya
this is macadamia natural oil deep
repair mask it's for your hair I cannot
take good care of my hair and that's it
that I hate washing my hair because it
takes long time to like dry and style so
I hardly wash my hair which is smart
because that's actually good for your
hair so I bought this at like a CVS one
time when I was traveling because I
figure if they're not going to be
washing my hair that often I may as well
do some sort of deep conditioning to it
but the times that I do wash it and this
works really really well also this comes
in a 3.3 fluid ounce tube which means
that you can travel with it in a
carry-on you connect yeah see yeah see
yeah see our Katya pure essential oils
shower tablet I was doing Amazon Prime
now order for just some odds and ends in
my house and I saw that this was
available in my Amazon store nearby and
so I added it to my cart I've had this
for weeks and I finally use it for the
first time last week and it's great this
is been purifying eucalyptus basically
it's just these tablets you open you put
on the floor of your shower and as the
hot water and steam collects they sort
of dissolve and they release just a very
pleasant eucalyptus scent all through
your showers it's like a bath bomb
before your shower
if tons of different scents just linger
afterwards so it's only met for the
purposes of your shower doesn't stain
anything smell weird color you just
literally put it in the class and just
let it sit like me at party snack yeah
can't see how I say this is a sex toy
home store
no planetarium star projector a lot of
fancy words for the fact that this
project starts on your ceiling and it's
so cool eventually if you are slightly
inebriated and you're listening to some
slightly emotional music I guess there's
months ago off of Amazon they make this
version which is I think the smallest
version and they make a bigger version
and then you can buy these discs here
that you slide into the system and when
you turn it on it projects stars over
your ceiling in various forms and you
can set it to rotates with slowly
rotates as if it's the real sky you can
set it to have shooting stars on it so
as if the stars actually shooting is so
indicative of the fact that I am such an
indoor child I could just go outside and
look at stars in Los Angeles there's not
many stars because there's so much light
pollution that happens so this is the
closest I can get without like renting
and Airbnb a few hours away I think it's
really cool I really like it I only have
two slides so I have to invest in some
more it's also great for date romantic
ambiance etc cool is it getting hot in
here I think it is hold on one second
well you know you're looking really good
I don't mean to jokes but it's not a hot
dog in my pocket I'm just happy to see
you okay
oh okay can you see ya see ya see ya
last thing on this month's favorites is
this short on talking to you which I
currently have available for sale for
you I represent calm such it's great 7
I'm doing a super super quick flash sale
so by the time this video goes up I
think there's like a day and a half left
of your ability to buy this t-shirt it
comes in white navy blue and gray I only
have it available until Thursday because
we want to make sure that we can ship it
to you by Valentine's Day so that you
can give your significant other the most
romantic thing that you've ever given
them and or you can wear it to pick up a
potential significant other because who
doesn't love the line is that a hot dog
in my pocket or am I just happy to see
you it's not perverted because you've
got a hot dog in your pocket I'll put
the link in the description box below if
you are interested in buying this
t-shirt I love it and I designed a
t-shirt myself with my hands if you saw
my snapshot last week or so I was
sketching out a bunch of different I
hung cartoons and so I did this all in
Photoshop so this is a design directly
from my hot dog to you and that's it I
hope you guys enjoyed this favorites
video if you did give it a thumbs up and
um let me know some of the stuff that
you have loved this month and if you
haven't already
sounds like you do you click this button
and subscribe to this YouTube channel if
you're on like a laptop or a desktop or
there's a button somewhere all around if
you're on a mobile device to subscribe
to this YouTube channel because you
might be a cool cat but I'm a hot dog I
thought about that joke hours ago and I
told myself I wouldn't use it verbally
or on social media and I just I broke my
own promise to myself hey o 2017 par for
the course I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
you